let me start by saying so I got to see
finally one of the shorts it was great
it wasn't it great it was so cute and I
think it's like one of those perfect
things were like kids will be able to
actually learn but yeah so funny and
beautifully done and typical Pixar
fashion and it's just what I love about
4k as it brings it down to the simplest
form like what's time what's money
what's friendship all that stuff right
did you do the recording for like all of
them at the same time no I did the
recording like two years ago for Toy
Story and then this was only like last
December but they had already had the
models for four key and all the sets and
all that kind of stuff so they really
the process was a little faster than the
movie you've done a lot of voicing a lot
of voice characters how is working at
Pixar similar and different to what
you've done previously yeah I would say
good question Steve broad tronic I would
say hey hex are even though I've I'm
grateful even to have the gigs but Pixar
did something that was very unique in
that you're usually separate from the
producer and writer and director but I
like this sheet of glass and you have
your headphones on and then though the
sound goes off and you're like and you
just see mouths like you don't know what
they're talking about but you know
they're talking about you
Pixar brought us all into the same room
so it was like the right of the person
everybody was in the same room so it
really created this kind of intimacy and
warmth that I think catered really well
to kind of the movie I think ask you
this at the Toy Story for chunky and I'm
just gonna ask you again now have they
provided you with the you know the
passport from life for Disneyland or
Disney World no they have not no they
have not Steve Weintraub and can you say
that again to the camera right Oh have
you gotten your passport for life for
Disneyland or Disney World
no I have not stifling Trev so what
about happen what about a free
subscription to Disney Plus no I have
not
[Music]
so let's say I get that swag going right
uh I actually think that the Disney Plus
format is the streaming service is gonna
be a massive huge show yeah it's a it's
gonna be ridiculous um what are you
is there another show on the format that
you're excited for or are you sort of
just yeah Jeff Goldblum's I such a huge
fan of his and he is so interesting to
me and just I know he paired with
National Geographic for this and just
watching him in these different
scenarios having these conversations I'm
just like I love him yeah I saw the
first two because Jeff's heared it also
yeah talk it's great he's just also his
style is interesting just everything
about him is interesting to me um
jumping back into four key you obviously
there's a ton of merchandise for this
character do you did you get sent a
bunch do you have a personal favorite -
no I didn't know I did I they were kind
enough to give me some really fun stuff
and it's so fun to have it because when
I meet kids who are four key fans they
give me these like little buttons or
magnets that I can hand out which is
really really fun yet V what I love also
about the short is that the animation
it's it's Pixar its Pixar it's so
beautiful and just the simple fact that
these when you look at it I don't even I
think I've mentioned this to you before
and during the during the Toy Story 4
junket but we are a very small slice of
this pie these voice talent most of the
pie is the work and the labor and the
artistry for years that have gone into
this movie like it's beautiful you we
saw each other at Disney World
yes you briefly got to experience some
of that did you have a favorite ride
what was it like being a VIP at Disney
where he didn't get a chance to go much
because as you know is I think I just
ripped my coat I
not giving I we did we were we were
pretty busy so I didn't get a chance to
go much queue passport no but I did ride
the avatar that ji droid the avatar
right that was fantastic because the the
raht the thing you were writing it would
like start moving and you really felt
the experience so it's pretty awesome
yeah it's unbelievable it's uh for
anyone who's watching this who's going
to Disney World
you want to go on that ride yeah it was
really good 100% um if I'm not mistaken
you did you create the show or the
Archibald's next big thing yeah but it
came from a book I did years ago about
this little chicken who's always looking
to his next thing and missing where he
is and this becomes around and it's like
you gotta just be man you gotta just be
and so in the series Netflix was kind
enough to pick it up to series and it
now he's a chicken who just sees the
best in everyone and the best in every
situation and he has a yes and attitude
to life and it is so much fun and
actually doing this cartoon archibald
has given me such a new appreciation for
what the tremendous amount of work that
goes into animation you also voiced a
character I believe on Harley Quinton I
did and which is a very different than
for a bit different but this goes back
to what I was saying which is you've
been very fortunate to be able to do a
lot of voice work mm-hmm
is it something that you ever thought
that you would be doing is it's like did
you ever go after it how did this all
land no and if I'm honest I used to when
I was younger I had a blood of
insecurities about my voice I just had
kind of like I don't know if it was I
remember this one teacher was just kind
of you know certain teachers will say
something that kind of gets stuck in
your head but he said something that was
just not very nice and it gave me this
insecurity about my voice so doing a lot
of animation has really given me a new
renewed confidence so because I really
love it and I love that just how crazy
you can go in the booth you know and you
just it can trust that it gets
communicated through the microphone
well it's pure imagination it's pure
imagination it's silly you play with
voices the at you can just ad lib as
much as you want
because they can always cut around it or
use it and it's just really fun of
course I'm gonna bring up veep for a
second yeah what is it like for you when
you go into the supermarket or when
people know you from that role and they
just hand me their back like is it
something to do people always want to
bring up certain things with you or is
it just one of these things where it's
like I love the show I had to tell you I
think that yeah I think they're always
just very kind and just say hey I love
the show I do love when since it's been
a while since I've been arrested I when
Arrested Development fans come up and
they say oh my gosh I love this part I
love this part ii love this part and I'm
always like I have no memory of what
they're talking about because I've
really only seen each episode maybe once
or twice and so when they start saying
humour went Buster did this I'm like I
have no idea what you're saying but
please tell me because it sounds
hilarious so it's fun to be kind of
reminded of of them of what Mitch
Hurwitz wrote um I have to stop there
and I'm just gonna say congrats on this
and I really and for people that don't
know how many episodes is this is ten
and it's what one a week it's one a week
I think they're putting out - the first
week and then one the week weeks after
and it's just like it's typical for KI
fashion just seeing the world very
simply and just simple truths and I love
that I cannot wait to finish them all
thanks man